David Packman Show at David Packman Dot.com.
We were scheduled to have four more Democratic
primary elections yesterday.
One was canceled.
That's Ohio, thanks to Republican Governor
Mike DeWine deciding that because of Corona
virus, Ohio would be postponing its primary.
In the end, it didn't matter.
The three that we had went to Joe Biden and
Bernie Sanders has announced he will be reassessing
his campaign, which is political code for
it's over.
Let's look at the numbers.
Let's look at what took place.
Three elections happened last night, Arizona,
Florida and Illinois going into yesterday
in terms of delegates.
Joe Biden was leading Bernie Sanders by 151
delegates, 894 to 7:43.
The results in yesterday's three primaries
are and of course, we like to compare to the
polling in Arizona.
Biden was winning by 18 in the polls, but
won only by 12 in Florida.
Biden was winning by thirty nine and won by
thirty nine.
And in Illinois, Biden was winning by twenty
nine and one by twenty three.
Biden underperforming the polls in two of
yesterday's three primaries.
This now pushes the delegate numbers to eleven
forty seven for Biden, 861 for Bernie.
Doing the math for you.
That's a 286 delegate lead for Joe Biden.
Now, as I had said before, if the delegate
lead ends at more than 200 after the March
17 primaries and certainly if it ends at more
than 250.
Bernie should suspend his campaign simply
because he has no path to the nomination.
And indeed, Bernie Sanders has announced he
is now assessing his campaign.
He says in the following weeks now, this again
is how you translate telegraph in political
code that it's over.
It's just a matter of when and how they structure
his exit in order to be as graceful as possible.
And to be clear, this really isn't close.
It's not you know, maybe if he sticks it out.
It is not close.
It's not clear Bernie has a path to winning
any more.
States may be won here or there.
The popular vote count is not close.
It is now about 2.5 million votes, a 4 in
favor of Joe Biden.
I said yesterday, you know, it may end up
larger than 2 million.
And I underestimated by about 25 percent.
Joe Biden leading by 2.5 million votes.
It's a massive lead.
And this is not about, you know, doing more
post-mortems.
We've done post-mortems.
We're in the middle of a crisis with the virus.
This is simply about it's not at all close.
And again, when Bernie will suspend, we don't
know.
We know that there was scheduled to be a March
24 primary in Georgia, which Biden was going
to win easily.
That's been postponed because of the virus.
Puerto Rico scheduled to vote on March 29
in April.
On April 4th, Alaska and Hawaii were scheduled
as well as Wyoming.
Again, not not very many delegates there.
April 7th in Wisconsin.
Twenty eighth of April, we were getting to
Connecticut, Delaware, Maryland, New York,
Pennsylvania and Rhode Island.
We have no idea whether those were going to
be postponed or will be.
But every indication I mean, listen, it's
we just don't know.
It's possible.
By the time you listen to this, Bernie will
be out.
It's possible.
Bernie really will take a couple of weeks,
given that we don't have any primaries coming
up in the immediate.
Other than Puerto Rico scheduled eleven days
from now, I don't know.
It's not clear what it makes sense to do.
And of course, we will be forced into discussing,
are we going to have conventions?
Are we going?
You know, how will the virus affect the remaining
trajectory of the primary?
The primary in all.
But the most technical sense is over as Joe
Biden has won three more primaries and easily.
And the big news, Bernie Sanders assessing
his campaign.
We deal with things as they are, not as as
not as we would wish them to be.
And these are the numbers we are dealing with.
I still had people tweet angrily tweeting
me today when I was commenting on Bernie's
announcement that he is assessing, which is
code for ending soon, saying, I am redoubling
down my efforts and donating money to Bernie.
I mean, I don't get you know, you whatever
your financial situation is, if you want to
donate to Bernie now, do it.
But to some degree, it seems like denialism
at this point in time.
And I don't totally get it.
That's money that could be used.
You know, it donate to some issue campaign.
If you don't care about Biden beating, beating
Trump.
Fine.
But I don't know why.
When Bernie says he's reassessing the campaign,
you would you would continue donating.
But maybe somebody can let me know.
This is the path forward.
We will have more coverage